good morning I'm Gord mills of the MD
Anderson Cancer Center and co-director
of the Khalifah Institute for
personalized cancer therapy this morning
I'm going to tell you about the program
in personalized cancer therapy at the md
anderson cancer center both what we're
doing the challenges the opportunities
and how we're going to be able to move
forward in this critically important
field now this is my potential conflict
of interests my institution requests
that i showed this at all presentations
i think it's important to stop and talk
about this for just a moment first of
these is that if we are going to help
our patients we need to develop a better
way to work with industry to develop
academic industrial collaborations that
are functional and effective so while we
need to take care and ensure that these
conflicts of interests are potential
conflicts of interests do not become
problems it is critically important that
we establish collaborations that we move
these forward and that these become
steps that go to helping our patients
and moving drugs to our patients in a
much more effective manner I'm going to
talk about that at several points
throughout my presentation now the
concept of personalized medicine or
personalized cancer therapy is not new
indeed a fellow Canadians or William
Osler stated as long ago as 1892 if it
were not for the great variability among
individuals medicine might as well be a
science and not an art so the concept
even then is that the variability among
individuals in their own genome and
particularly in cancer and cancer
genomes had to be something that we
dealt with in order to help our patients
in the most efficient manner
now this is the mantra of personalized
medicine and it's one that has been
around for over a decade and I'm going
to tell you that I've changed this or
modified it slightly the concept of
personalized medicine has been to give
the right dose of the right drug for the
right indication for the right patient
but in terms of cancer care the key term
here is the first time the first time we
treat the patient is our best
opportunity to get it right and improve
the outcomes for our patients now what
I'm going to talk about today is really
a revolution in how we think about
cancer care in the past we have used
relatively blunt instruments
chemotherapy radiation therapy primarily
targeting the proliferating the tumor
now we have an opportunity to
characterize each patient and their
tumor with omics technologies genomics
transcriptomics proteomics at a breadth
and depth never before possible indeed
we have entered the era where we can
consider analyzing a complete genome or
at least the genome that is actionable
in a cancer patient for under a thousand
dollars so the technology is here the
question is is what are we going to do
with it and importantly are we going to
be able to use this technology to help
our patients indeed one of the
opportunities of targeted therapies is
understanding what is happening in the
patient's tumor sufficiently to be able
to capitalize on the vulnerabilities
that that cancer has it turns out that
systems are robust and indeed i had a
department of systems biology at the md
anderson cancer center and the concept
behind that is that through phylogeny
evolution systems have become extremely
robust of perturbations indeed as a
geneticist it surprises me that any
individual survives and grows to become
an adult with all of the things that can
go wrong further the things that we do
to ourselves the tox is it toxins in the
environment the caffeine in the coffee
we drink the cigarette smoke our major
challenges to individual cells indeed
the amount of caffeine that I've
consumed already this morning if put in
a tissue culture dish would kill each of
the cells in that tissue culture dish
however in the body those cells have the
ability to enter into a quiescent state
or adapt to the stress that I have
placed on the cell and wait until
there's such a time as they can go back
to function further one of the
opportunities in cancer is that they
have lost those robust networks the very
underlying genomic instability that
leads to the development of cancer may
indeed be the cancers Achilles heel they
no longer have robust systems that when
we perturb them with targeted therapies
and in particular rational combinations
of targeted therapies that the cancer
cell will have little opportunity or
little choice but to die indeed I think
we are entering into an era that is
incredibly exciting we can now talk
about the concept of letting the patient
teach us what is important each patient
has a story and if we can just
understand that story we will be able to
help patients like them the concept of a
patient like me from someone we've
treated previously and had great results
is moving forward at a rate that we've
never seen before and I'm going to come
back on that but there's another part to
this perfect storm the first that I've
already mentioned is our ability to
characterize the tumor and a breadth and
depth never before possible with speed
and cost efficiency but the other part
is we've now developed a drug toolkit
there are hundreds of drugs moving
through the pipeline's that target
particular aberrations in patients
tumors now we can just figure out how to
use these optimally how to develop
rational combinations and which patients
we should treat with each of these
combinations we have an opportunity to
move forward in a way that we've never
had before
I want to point out that this targeted
therapy toolkit is really quite
impressive there's almost a thousand
drugs either in or about to enter into
clinical trials those drugs are spread
across different diseases but for
example here there's over a hundred that
are being evaluated in breast cancer and
lung cancer alone one of the big
challenges is that we know that we need
to do rational combination therapy
targeting more than one aberration in
the tumor cell if we're going to have
the success that we need and if one
simply thinks about the concept of
testing a hundred drugs and a hundred
different combinations there simply are
not enough patience to determine whether
those combinations will work and indeed
we have to move from the concept of a
rational drug combination of two drugs
from the same company to really where we
start to look at two drugs that we put
together because they take care of the
challengers raised by each other the
idea that we treat the adaptation of the
tumor cell to the responses now I
mentioned earlier this concept that we
have to work with industry what they do
what they develop the drugs they develop
are truly impressive indeed there is
approximately a twenty billion dollar
annual R&D investment in industry and
the pharmaceuticals and biotechnology
industries we need to capitalize on that
effort if we are going to help our
patients efficiently now this slide is
busy I apologize just a little bit for
it but I'm going to show you some points
in the slide that I think are very
important and the reason it's busy is
that I built this slide many years ago
when there were only two or three
different targeted therapies that were
in the clinic and we're showing activity
but I want to show you a couple of
messages that come from this particular
slide and the key one is is that most
effective targeted agents are linked to
response prediction biomarkers in the
absence of a biomarker that says this
patient is likely to benefit or a
biomarker that says that patient is not
likely to benefit we will have little
activity and little utility now what
started this excitement was a drug
called madness
sulit in chronic myelogenous leukemia
that targets the BCR Abel translocation
unfortunately or at least part of this
story that is important the BCR Abel
translocation was discovered in 1982 it
took well over 30 years before we had an
effective therapy approved targeting
this aberration however the important
part here is that imatinib mesylate and
CML probably taught us away not the way
we should do things but away from what
we should do it was thought at the time
that imatinib mesylate was introduced
that if you had a disease in this case
chronic myelogenous leukemia and a drug
that matched that disease imatinib
mesylate you would have incredible
responses what we forgot is that CML is
primarily a disease defined by an
underlying genomic aberration this BCR
Abel translocation now I want to skip
down this list to a couple of different
examples that I think are very important
as we consider it but I do want to just
note that we have a number of highly
effective drugs that are working across
different diseases that have been
approved many not as quickly as we would
like but I want to drop down to
crizotinib here which came into use and
lung cancer a little while ago but what
was exciting is that in lung cancer a
group in Japan identified an aberration
of a fusion gene called EML for elk elk
happens to be a kinase very much like
the able aberration in the BCR Abel
translocation so it was thought if we
could find a drug that would target elk
we would be able to move this forward to
the clinic and really what was very
exciting is that crizotinib a drug was
being developed for a completely
unrelated reason and indeed using an
antibody that I developed many years ago
was shown to be active against elk this
led to a large clinical trial and indeed
from four years from the time of
discovery of the EML for elk fusion gene
to implementation and approval by the
FDA
so this is a massive switch from the 30
years from identification to therapy in
the imatinib mesylate story to that of
crizotinib for years in the current era
it is hoped that with this drug toolkit
and the ability to match patients we
will see many more examples of this
rapid translation for translation to the
clinic and ability to help patients that
we have not seen previously now I want
to note that almost all of the drugs on
this list target what we call oncogene
addiction the tumor has an underlying
genomic aberration that drives the
behavior of the tumor they are addicted
to that driving event and indeed as long
as we can identify an addicting event we
have a targeted therapy with an adequate
therapeutic index we can expect to have
marked activity in patients tumors there
are three exceptions on this list one
that I do want to bring up are the parp
inhibitors brca1 two is our major
players in DNA repair there are a
limited number of DNA repair pathways
and a patient with an abnormality in
brca1 or brca2 as defective DNA repair
with limited options left to repair the
damage that happens every time a cell
divides if we instead target one of the
other pathways for DNA repair one that
is mediated by Park we can now induce a
synthetic lethality BRCA 1 2 does not
mutations do not harm the tumors in
theory PARP inhibitors will not have
major side effects on dividing cells but
when you put those two together only the
tumor cells have the abnormality and you
will obtain hopefully a synthetic
lethality that results in benefit to the
patient and indeed in a number of trials
including ones that we are running we
have seen remarkable activity
particularly when we use these parts
inhibitors in combination with other
drugs but I do want to go down to two of
these at the bottom very briefly and
that is is that the most effective
targeted therapy and
need the one that we have used for the
longest time is an androgen receptor
inhibitor tamoxifen tamoxifen and AIS
and breast cancer targeting a lineage
event a an expression of the estrogen
receptor that is important for the
lineage of cells that become luminal
breast cancer so we're not targeting
something that is related to the
tumorigenic process rather a critical
event in the differentiation of the cell
of interest and indeed chronic
lymphocytic leukemia targeting btk a key
regulator of the b-cell receptor
signaling gives you the same types of
responses and these are targeting
lineage events now let me point out that
there are a number of other targeted
therapies where we don't have effective
biomarkers PA GFR inhibitors proteasome
inhibitors and indeed i'll contend the
limited activity of these drugs is
related to a great degree from not being
able to identify patients likely to
benefit and I'm going to come back to
this concept that I've pointed out here
that the efficacy of a drug requires a
predictive biomarker and that those
predictive biomarkers are a combination
of the underlying driving aberrations in
the tumor the aberrations that occur in
concert the co mutations and the lineage
of the tumor cell now this sounds great
however there are challenges I'm going
to talk about the challenges at a number
of different levels the first is is that
their response isn't only a subset of
patients our biomarkers today have
strong negative predictive value that is
less than five percent of patients
without the biomarker can be expected to
respond in contrast the positive
predictive value is much weaker
somewhere between thirty to sixty
percent of patients with the biomarker
are expected to respond to these drugs
the biggest problem is that most of
these responses tend to be short there
are many different resistance mechanisms
and if we're going to have effective
targeted therapy we're going to need to
figure out how to target those
resistance mechanism
unfortunately resistance appears to be
dominant over sensitivity one of the
best examples of this is the epidermal
growth factor receptor and rasmussen if
you have an epidermal growth factor
receptor mutation you will be sensitive
in most cases to drugs targeting the
EGFR however if you have a concurrent
Rask mutation and that's not an unusual
event in bowel cancer and even lung
cancer you will have limited benefit
from the drug similar examples have come
up with her to targeted therapy with
aberrations in pi3 kinase and p10 as we
showed many years ago and more recent
data showing that if you have a
collaboration in the met oncogene and
her to you are unlikely to have
significant benefit something that I'm
not going to dwell on to a major degree
today is the other aspect I mentioned
earlier that a therapeutic index is
critical to what will happen in terms of
being able to target a molecule of
interest it is the patient's own genomic
makeup not the makeup of the tumor that
determines the metabolism of the drug
and the toxicity to the individual and
that defines the therapeutic index in
concert with what is going on in terms
of the tumor responsiveness I said I'm
going to talk about the challenges in
many cases and indeed i think that the
challenges are greater than we initially
thought as we entered this field and a
real question I think is arisen as to
whether we can truly achieve
personalized cancer therapy we run into
an end of one problem every tumor is
different every patient is different can
we obtain enough information and enough
commonality so that we will know which
patients are likely to benefit from each
drug indeed I think we're moving to an
era where we talk about precision
medicine or stratified medicine treating
more and more homogeneous patient groups
unfortunately that means smaller and
smaller groups of patients are likely to
benefit from any particular therapy as
we move forward this can be a trouble or
a problem in proving that the therapy
that we're interested in will actually
benefit
our patients for example ductal breast
cancer the most common cancer and women
has now been demonstrated to be a
minimum of eight independent
therapeutically relevant subclasses
instead of being one of the easiest
diseases to perform clinical trials it
is now a set of orphan diseases and
indeed in one of the aberrations are one
of the subtypes of breast cancer that we
identified or we identified the
aberrations for claudin low or
metaplastic cancers there are particular
aberrations that could be targeted
therapeutically however it has been very
hard to mount a trial to prove that
those targeted therapeutics work the
other challenge that we are entering
into is that the aberrations that we
want to target are particularly rare
across tumors or may be sufficiently
rare as to make this challenging and I'm
going to talk about this in several
examples as we move forward one of the
molecules that I work on called a Katie
part of the pi3 kinase signaling pathway
that I'll show you in a few minutes is
mutated in perhaps two to three percent
of breast cancers however as we look
across patient sets in our clinics we
find that under one percent or
approximately one percent of an
abnormality in a Katie now if we had a
drug that worked in one percent of all
cancer patients that would be wonderful
the challenge however is how do we
determine or identify those individuals
the other that we are finding as we move
forward and have testing app
opportunities that we can look at many
different things in a tumor is that the
amount of titian tissue that we have
frequently is limiting that the limited
amount of tumor can result in challenges
to test all of the different events that
we need to do and as I mentioned a
moment ago resistance is dominant one of
the ways in which we are doing it
dealing with this problem and trying to
understand how to move forward is to
doing prospective analysis of many
different genes at the same time amer
tising the costs of testing all of those
jeans at once
across a large number of patients to
determine what patients are best to go
in which particular trial and which
drugs may benefit our patients now we've
been doing this in the Khalifa Institute
for personalized cancer therapy at the
md anderson cancer ther institute and we
have a mission and vision that i think
is important and i'll start with the
mission and that is is that we're going
to determine how to personalize cancer
therapy for all of our patients i'll
mention how much of a challenge that is
in a moment but one of the key things
that we need to do is to define the new
standard of patient care that is only
going to happen if we show that we
attain durable responses leading to
cures or at least the equivalent of cure
by converting cancer into chronic
disease and reducing the cost of patient
management these processes are
relatively expensive when one looks at
this in total however when we look at
each individual patient or each
individual gene that we are testing the
costs really are modest compared to what
it would be if we were looking at doing
a cat scan or any other similar analysis
of the patient but if we don't determine
how to make this available and pale but
we're not going to move it forward now
in our if the md anderson cancer center
in the institute we see approximately
30,000 new patients a year this is an
engineering problem to characterize what
is happening in their genome broadly and
indeed we're looking probably a testing
and analyzing at this point in time
somewhere between four and six thousand
patients a year what we want to do is to
characterize what we call actionable
aberrations and I use the term mutations
here to refer to anything that happens
in the genome actionable is something
that we can do something about one of
those of course would be if we had a
targetable event an aberration that we
could target either directly or by
targeting the pathway that it influences
we would also want to know whether they
would predict patient outcomes could we
have a prognostic indicator that would
allow us to improve patient managed
the technology has to be paraffin
compliant because that is the tissue
that we have available to us and I'll
talk a little bit about the need for
proximal biopsies as compared to
biopsies that we did many years
previously for those patients where a
targetable aberration is present and
I'll show you some numbers in a few
minutes many of them will have standard
of care drugs drugs targeting the EGF
receptor in lung cancer b-raf and
melanoma what we use this for most
efficiently is to fill clinical trial
cohorts to test the concept that if one
has a pi3 kinase aberration will a pi3
kinase targeted drug work or not we can
answer those questions quickly and where
the answer is yes we get those drugs
through to our patients in a much more
efficient manner and actually let
everyone in the world benefit from this
information the other that we do which
is much more challenging is test the
process ask whether going through the
process of obtaining this data matching
the patient to a drug based on the
underlying abnormalities in its tumor
will benefit the patient this is not to
ask whether each drug works not to ask
whether there is a link of one drug to
one particular aberration but rather to
test the process and this has become a
challenge and an opportunity
unfortunately for many of our patients
when we look at an actionable genome we
do not find an aberration that we can
act upon and in many of those cases we
will characterize those tumors and
exquisite depth as a learning process to
let the patient teach us what is
important one of the key components of
that is not only do we identify the
aberration but we determine whether it
is a driver by high-throughput
biological validation a driver being
something that drives the behavior of
the tumor and if we had a drug for that
driver we could benefit the patient as
we attain more and more information of
that type we can go to the
pharmaceutical industry and hopefully
convince them that this is something
they should build drugs to
in concert with academic efforts today
I'm going to use the pi3 kinase pathway
as one of my major examples as we move
forward to show you some of the
principles the pi3 kinase pathway links
the membrane through a number of
signaling events this is pi3 kinase
itself this is the akt i mentioned a few
moments ago p 10 min a major negative
regulator all the way through to almost
all of the important things that are
happening in the cell this particular
pathway is aberrant in more patients and
more diseases in terms of activation
than any other pathway targeting an
activating event is relatively easy and
indeed this pathway is chock-full of
kinase is that we know how to target
efficiently this is not escaped industry
these are just some of the drugs that
are currently in clinical evaluation
from different companies asking what is
the best drug in terms of pharmacology
what are the best targets in the
particular pathway is it pi3 kinase
itself is it a katie is an mtor where
would you like to block the pathway at
the top with a growth factor receptor
inhibitor or down at the infect or arm
say at an mtor s6 kinase inhibitor these
questions are being asked rapidly and
efficiently and we shouldn't have
answers for many of these soon I want to
show you some of our early data from
Genco at all it's already published from
our phase 1 program it gives us I think
some important lessons to pay attention
to so this is a waterfall plot patients
that benefit it over here at the right
and the patients that really their tumor
kept on growing at the left and what we
have is these diseases are coded by the
lineage in color and I want to note that
all of these patients were tested with
multiplex testing as I mentioned
previously and all of them have
aberrations in a single molecule pik3ca
now in a phase 1 trial this is
remarkable with the resist criteria of
thirty percent where were forty percent
of our patients benefiting so linking a
targeting the aberration seems to be
highly active as we would expect less
than ten percent to respond in any
normal phase one trial however I want to
point out I think that there are much
more important lessons in this
particular figure the first is is that
these patients over here on the left are
read their bowel cancers of various
types in a reality they do not seem to
benefit from these drugs despite having
the pic 3 CH mutations now I mentioned
earlier that bowel cancers have frequent
aberrations in K rats and we thought
that would be the problem and indeed
some of these patients do have
abnormalities Cole mutations in K rafts
but that doesn't seem to be the sole
reason why they're resistant because
over here we have patients with
mutations in chaos and b-raf in ovarian
cancer that benefited from the pi3
kinase aberrations indeed as we look at
this group it happens to be the set of
women's cancers that I work on cervix
cancer and Demetrio cancer breast cancer
ovarian cancer and we are attempting to
understand why these tumor lineages are
particularly sensitive to these targeted
therapeutics I just want to show you a
couple of pictures to show that this is
real here is an endometrial cancer and a
patient who it had extensive treatment
previously and after 18 weeks this has
had a massive shrinkage in size there's
an ovarian cancer with to pelvic masses
one here and here and after 18 weeks
this one is decreased markedly and this
one is essentially scar tissue so this
really does work even in phase 1 trials
with single agents suggesting that if we
can just figure out how to do this
better and what rational combinations to
use we have the opportunity to benefit
our patients so with this in mind we
have done a major effort in our acting
program that we call clearing house
where in patients are identified by the
physician and I apologize for not
updating this this is a little older
slide we have now tested over 6,000
patients in the program we obtained
tissue usually from a previously
existing paraffin block a bio
if it's clinically indicated we then do
clear and CLIA testing in our pathology
and lab medicine environment using a
hotspot analysis of either 46 or 50
jeans now followed by when it's
appropriate full-length sequencing of
400 genes that have been implicated in
cancer as I mentioned earlier we're
looking for actionable events we have a
database development that allows us to
link these aberrations to patient trials
that is clicked critically important we
have a queryable database of patients
and mutations and a decision support
tumor board and I'm going to come back
to how important it is to provide
information to our physicians that links
this incredible trove of new information
through to how you would help manage
patients we do an enormous amount of
data capture not only to ask whether
this works but how would we do this
better in the future I'm going to talk a
little bit about the number of patients
that we would expect to go on trials in
one of these programs we do have major
research programs going on in parallel
with this where we more extensively
characterized what is happening in the
patient's tumor in the non CLIA
environment again to design our next
trial I want to show you some results
from the first 2,000 patients that we
analyzed at the end of last year this is
based on hotspot mutational analysis and
what we find is that about fifty percent
of our patients have a potentially
actionable event I want to note that we
do not count p53 is actionable although
there are some particular drugs and
mutations that you can test it's not
generally something we can do anything
about it's a tumor suppressor and
targeting lost events is hard we have
counted k rass and i think this is
somewhat controversial k rass may or may
not be targetable depending on what
you're looking at but we do have studies
today that are looking at targeting k
rats and a number of different diseases
and there's a major effort at the NCI
today to develop drugs that will target
k rest but if we look at these mutations
you'll see
that almost half of our patients have
nothing that we can target a bit with
drugs available today p53 is the most
common then we come into a suite of
targets k wrasse pik3ca b-raf idh1 and
raster which drugs are available and
these are in the five percent range but
I want to point out that we have a tale
of things that are important but
potentially problematic this includes
for example the akt that I talked about
earlier p10 egfr in the whole population
that we're looking at these are
sufficiently rare that it is going to be
difficult to prove that we have drugs
that work now in some tumor lineages
these are much more common making the
processes easier but I want to show you
the example of akt once again so a katie
is mutated in about one point percent of
cancers overall two percent of breast
cancers so we decided we would go to a
company that has an akt drug there are
actually four different companies that
have a kt drugs together and offer to do
testing of patients and in rural
patients with aberrations in a katie on
the clinical trial so for example if we
tested 2500 patients we would expect to
enroll about 25 patients this is not the
number that you would predict from the
percentage of akt but rather from the
fact that many of the patients would not
be trial eligible some would reject the
trial and it turns out that this would
be about eight hundred dollars per test
in our laboratory and it would be two
million dollars just to do the testing
now the company looked at this and said
that's wonderful you've got to be
kidding not going to happen however as I
mentioned we already do multiplex
testing of all of our patients in this
pathway and we've in this process and
we've actually identified 29 patients
with akt mutations across different
diseases most of them breast cancer as I
mentioned earlier and those patients are
now being enrolled in clinical trials
specifically designed to ask if we
target akt will we benefit our patients
now I also want to note that it depends
on what tumor or what disease you are
looking at and so once again if I take
that same concept of what patients have
potentially actionable events when we
look at melanoma and skin cancer it's
almost seventy-five percent colon at
seventy percent and we get down to safa
Geale cancers sarcomas prostate cancer
it's really a much lower event so all of
these things that I'm come n tioning
mean that we need to start thinking
about targeted therapy as a combination
of mutation lineage and the co mutations
that generate resistance and looking at
any one of those in isolation is going
to make our life much more challenging
now one of the things that we are
developing from this information is a
series of umbrella trials umbrella
trials are where you test all of the
patients with a particular disease and
then work with industry this academic
industrial collaboration that I have
been talking about to put in place a
comprehensive drug approach to all of
the aberrations that you have in the
tumor the idea here is they do amortize
the cost of the testing which is
non-trivial over many different trials
many of you may have seen these types of
figures from for lung cancer and this is
where it is best developed but i do want
to point out that if you were to do this
in breast cancer our example and one of
the umbrellas we're building at the md
anderson cancer center over half of the
patients have a targeted therapy quite a
broad list that one might use now note
about thirty percent of breast cancer
patients have no actionable aberration
about thirty percent of them have p53 as
their only targetable aberration and we
have the big ones pik3ca other parts of
that pathway but we do have rare events
and many other aberrations where we have
drugs b-raf k rafts things that drugs
are in the clinic or available that
could be used to test the hypothesis now
these particular trials I think are
critically important but come with a
number of challenges first
one is is how do we cover the cost of
testing thousands of patients how do we
get all of the drugs from industry
getting different companies to
collaborate with these drugs how do we
obtain proximal biopsies biopsies of the
disease we want to treat and finally
what are we going to offer patients
without actionable mutations if we have
to tell half of our patients that this
isn't going to benefit them will they
enter on the trials we have another type
of trial which is called a basket trial
and a basket trial is a concept where
you look across many different diseases
for a single aberration and then test
whether that were work and I already
mentioned that concept around akt1 but I
want to show you one more and just
mention these others very briefly the
first one is brca1 and 2 that I
mentioned we have parp inhibitors that
look highly effective the RCA 1 and 2 is
primarily found to be a parent in breast
and ovarian cancer and we removed all of
the breast and ovarian cancers from this
analysis but as we look at the patients
that we see at the md anderson cancer
center almost ten percent of them have a
definable aberration in brca1 and 2 no
one disease has enough to make a
practical trial however if we combine
this ten percent of all cancers it is
very worthwhile if we can identify
patients will benefit alka mutations
thirty percent akt i'm sorry three
percent akt the one to two percent we
talked about tsc one or two in the pi3
kinase pathway mtor and a KT
amplification all of these in the pi3
kinase pathway add up to significant
number of patients across many different
diseases but best on is a basket trial
not asking which drug in which disease
but rather is does this drug when linked
to a particular target show efficacy
I think there's an important concept in
challenge that we need to list I've
showed you that many of the aberrations
that we see in patients do not have
drugs that are effective today so if we
were to go in and just asked a simple
question of how many patients could
possibly go on trials and what actually
happens at the md anderson cancer center
we find that if we were to do hotspot
mutational analysis of the 50 genes most
highly implicated in cancer the
theoretical number of aberrations and
i'm taking out both p53 and rass here is
thirty-five percent of those patients at
any one time we only have trials at the
md anderson cancer center for about
twenty percent and finally if we ask
what number could even theoretically go
on trial if we put these two together
it's about eleven percent so you will
test a hundred patients to be able to
put one sorry to put ten patients or
eleven patients on a clinical trial
linking their aberration with what is
going on now given that only four to
five percent of patients going trials
today this is a remarkable improvement
but it really leaves us wanting to do
better if instead we characterize a
larger panel 200 genes or so and
sequence a full length of those complete
genes anything that is actionable rather
than just looking at hot spots our
theoretical number drops jumps to about
fifty three percent for the total
population about thirty percent would
have trials and an actual number where
we would expect about seventeen percent
to grow on trials that is a great number
I want to note that the rate limiting
factor in this is having the targeted
therapy trials and despite the fact that
we have 900 trials open at the md
anderson cancer center today we're
looking at really less than half of our
patients with an aberration having a
trial for that particular aberration one
of the other challenges that we will
have to deal with as we move for
word is when we test patients we will
not only find what is happening in their
tumor but also what is happening in
their germline we will find hereditary
abnormalities in a number of genes such
as brca1 brca2 p53 p10 that are high
penetrance autosomal dominant mutations
that have very major implications for
the patient and their family and each
institution that does this is going to
need to develop an approach to convey
this information to patients we really
have limited recommendations for how to
do this today but it is something that
needs to be on our horizon we will also
see things in pharmacogenomics I
mentioned earlier what dose of what drug
to use and finally what do we do when
there are other problems that are
related to the aberrations that are not
cancer for example hyper coagulation
states unpreventable diseases for
example a predisposition to Alzheimer's
disease something that we can do nothing
about now one of the things that I've
pointed out is we are generating an
incredible amount of information on
every patient and this information is
something that we worked talked how to
deal with in medical school and is
evolving at an incredible rate how is it
that we are going to develop medical
decision support that is going to tell
us what to do the past our patient has
expected the physician to know
everything how are we going to take this
barcode of information the incredible
trove that we can get from omics
technology and tell us what to do for
that patient it is not as simple as
laying back and being read on a barcode
scanner at the md anderson cancer center
we have developed a personalized cancer
therapy website that will help
physicians in this process you can find
this at PCT MD Anderson org it is
publicly available you can also search
on personalized cancer therapy with no
spaces between those words on Google and
it'll take you to the site this gives us
a lot of information the site will
contain
you to be developed and matured right
now we have information on the 14 most
important for textually actionable jeans
you can look for what happens with
mutations copy number changes fusions
germline alterations if relevant it is
interactive the physician can determine
how much information they want to attain
from a very superficial view of saying
what clinical trial could I use for this
patient to going all the way down to the
in-depth analysis of each paper saying
why we gave you the conclusions that we
gave you and the key is is that we're
telling you the therapeutic implications
not of an aberration in the gene but of
the specific abnormality that your
patient has and the level of evidence
that we have to tell us what you should
do with this information it is also
linked at least in the United States to
clinical trials that are available not
only at the md anderson cancer center
but anywhere else in the country that
we're able to track and find i want to
tell you a couple of stories and i
apologize a couple of my slides and
little glitches in the mac IBM a switch
here this is a fairly old story but
around the concept that the patient can
teach us things that are very important
and we finally have the tools to learn
from those patients I mentioned earlier
that five to ten percent of patients and
early clinical trials demonstrate
remarkable responses and we started this
particular study a long time ago just as
b-raf was being shown to be an
abnormality of importance in melanoma
there was a drug available called
sorafenib that was thought to be a good
drug targeting b-raf it turns out it's
not it's not a particularly good b-raf
inhibitor and we did a trial of 22
patients one of those patients responded
remarkably with their disease going away
and staying away so the question was is
what can this patient teach us is this
patient teaching us that they had an
abnormality in b-raf because it was a
melanoma and that's why they responded
or is there another lesson
and indeed we went in and characterized
this patient in great detail there was
no abnormality and b-raf at all this is
the results in this patient I do want to
show you that this really is remarkable
here is a metastatic lesion to the long
this is the lesion after two months of
therapy importantly eight years later
this lesion is still gone and the
patient is essentially cured of their
melanoma that is remarkable it's
surprising so we needed to learn what
this patient could teach us so we did
the in-depth characterization that we
talked about and there was no mutation
in b-raf or any graph family members we
went back to the drawing board and said
what's going on well we knew that sera
fandom targeted kinase a--'s so we
looked at all of the possible kinases
and found what was clearly a causal
mutation in kit this was a mutation that
is rare in other diseases that have
abnormalities in kit al 576 p doesn't
matter what it is I'll mention it again
in a moment but following this initial
patient response we went in and
characterized melanoma extensively and
found that thirty percent of a Crone
nichoza and chronic skin skin damage
melanomas have abnormalities and kit
this is now part of our standard
approach for these patients and further
they receive get targeted therapy and
i'll talk about its efficacy in a few
moments what made this even more
exciting as this patient came in about
two weeks after we had completed this
study and found that kit was important
that we had a drug targeting kit turns
out that dis at nib is a little better
drunk than sorafenib for this approach
but here's the patient and this is a PET
scan of their pelvis this patient was
such that we had to get special
permission to treat them because their
performance status was minimal this is
after one month this disease is
quiescent the patient's improvement in
quality of life was remarkable we did
not cure this patient however it was a
beautiful proof of concept that this
process was important and that indeed we
should
expand it further and we have a major
program at the md anderson cancer center
and we will work with anyone in the
world with similar patients any patient
with a marked response in clinical
trials here we're talking about complete
or near complete or a mixed response one
lesion goes away and another stays we
will obtain a biopsy of the patient's
tumor at response and it recurrence and
then perform extensive analysis
initially we'll look at those candidate
genes and ask if the expected biomarker
is present wonderful clinical validation
of our hypothesis but if not we will
move on to deep sequencing and determine
what is happening we believe that this
is going to be the best way that we have
to identify new targets and new drugs
and biomarkers that will link the target
to the drug I want to go through a
couple of other challenges fairly
quickly and the first one of those is
what do we do when we are treating a
patient unfortunately today we treat
patients based on the original biopsy
what we're worried about is the
metastatic tumor because we can usually
remove that local tumor and does that
primary tumor represent the metastasis
and indeed in many cases we are treating
a recurrent tumor that is not only
spatially but also temporarily distant
from when we obtained the original
biopsy so does the primary tumor
represent the metastatic or recurrent
tumor are there subclones are they
selected and does it matter this is a
beautiful paper from another group
published in the New England Journal on
intratumoral heterogeneity and renal
cancer and what I just want to point out
is if you look at heterogeneity within
the original tumor in different sites it
is present and if we look at different
metastases we find that there are
mutations that are quite different in
each of these sites however when we look
at that in a little more detail and ask
about evolution of the tumor we find
this and we now have a study from the md
anderson cancer center with many more
patients showing that this concept is
right
going from normal tissue to cancer there
is a truncal event a major dominant or
dominant series of events that if
targetable would affect all of the tumor
cells the other that is important is
that although you have branches many of
these branches have convergent evolution
this particular tumor has vhl is its
truncal event but note in all of the
branches there's an abnormality in
another gene called set D 2 so that set
D 2 abnormality is important and
co-occurs with vhl in every tumor cell
that this patient has however once you
get out to the mutations that are
happening distally in the leaves you may
only affect part of the tumor for
example here here is an aberration and
mtor that is only found in some tumor
cells here's one in kdms see these are
different mutations and it turns out
that over ninety percent of the tumors
will have at least three common events
so if we can identify these dominant
events and target them we would be much
more efficient we've looked across a
large series of breast cancers with a
number of questions and first of them is
is that at least eighty percent of the
breast cancers do not appear to have
major intratumoral heterogeneity in
targetable events I'm not saying they
don't have had our Jenaya t but rather
those things which we target tend to be
truncal events and dominant and so we
could move forward with them now one of
the questions is does it matter so this
is an early analysis that we did just
asking about the prognostic impact of a
very simple question erp are her two and
asked whether there was a discordant
between the primary and the Mets would
it matter and this is if you have the
same result in the primary in the Met
and if you have discordant it is a much
worse tumor so the very fact that you
have heterogeneity indicates a worse and
outcome this is another study from the
MD Anderson Cancer Center asking exactly
the same question with her too and once
again exactly the same conclusions
concordance
you do better than if it is discordant
so having multiple clones in the tumor
is an indication of a worsened outcome
in and of itself this particular study
indicates that it's not treatment it is
actually prognosis this is a very
interesting case from colleagues in
Denmark where they had a breast cancer
similar to ones we're looking at where
they looked only at pi3 kinase they
found about a fifty percent discords
between primary and metastasis similar
to what we're seeing but they had an odd
observation where the primary had no
mutation in pi3 kinase the metastasis
had this mutation second Matassa
metastasis at this one and what they
found is is if you put a needle in or
were to put a needle in this area in the
primary tumor was wild type this had one
mutation this had the other mutation
this is a case of convergent mutation we
have a paper from md anderson not my
laboratory impress that suggests if you
just very deeply sequence any place in
this tumor you would get all of this
information the depth of sequencing then
matters I also want to point out that we
have one other opportunity that may help
us and that is looking at circulating
DNA tumor cells release DNA from the
tumor into the circulation we can
measure that we can determine
abnormalities and we may actually be
able to go in and by looking at what is
in the circulation capture information
on all tumor types in the patient our
studies right now show somewhere between
an 85 and a ninety percent concordance
between what we find in the primary
tumor and what we find in the
circulation suggesting that this may
resolve many of the problems so we are
going to have to deal with intratumoral
heterogeneity biopsy biopsy biopsy is a
critical point we're going to need with
circuit do this with circulating DNA and
circulating tumor cells now I'm going to
finish off very briefly with just a
couple of comments and I'm not going to
walk you through the slides but one of
the challenges that we have when we look
at data from a patient is determining
whether the ever
that they have as a driver that is if we
were to target it would behave what I
change the behavior of the tumor or
isn't a passenger having that
information is critically important
because one does not want to target
passengers it will not be effective
Boris Bastian did a clinical trial to
ask this question and indeed where he
found that particular mutations again
this kit mutation that I was talking
about earlier that 576 p is a driver
forty percent of the patients will
respond if you have another mutation and
kit but it is not a driver it's zero so
we need to know not just what the
aberration is in a gene but whether the
aberration is a driver or passenger the
future is coming it's going to be biopsy
biopsy biopsy imaging blood circulating
tumor cells to determine what's
happening in the patient characterize
these to the depth that we need to
identify subclones perform a trial of
therapy biopsy recurrences determine why
they record and select your next therapy
hopefully this will result in marked
benefit for our patients thank you are
there questions okay so there are a
number of questions I'm going to go
through as many of these as we can until
the termination of the time that's
available however if you have further
questions you're welcome to send them to
me by email and I will answer as many as
I can it's G mills at MD Anderson org
the first one of these is are there any
new developments with GI colon CML I
think one of the most exciting
developments now is that we understand
why b-raf inhibitors are not effective
in colon cancers with mutations in beer
after uggs that are moving forward that
will help this particular process
now the second question I think is one
that I alluded to earlier around the
concept of how the patient's genome
determines drug metabolism and
therapeutic index should we be analyzing
the patient's genome to determine what
drug to use and also what dosage of
drugs and while I would say that this is
probably one of the most critically
important things we should be doing so
far this has not been effective for most
of the drugs that we use and I think
that this area of pharmacogenomics is
one that is going to require major
effort over the next five or ten years
now I have another question here which
is around the concept of personalized
stem cell therapy and I'm going to add
in the combination of personalized
immunotherapy over personalized drug
cancer therapy and where do I think we
are in terms of those approaches and one
of the things i do want to mention is
that it is incredibly exciting that the
promise of immunotherapy which has been
around for generations is finally
beginning to be realized through
checkpoint therapy however even there
it's only a portion of patients that
benefit my expectation is that as we
move forward we are not going to stop
doing chemotherapy and radiation therapy
they are extremely effective for a
population of patients will do a better
job of knowing who is going to benefit
we will then look at the best way for
each patient to use the armamentarium of
targeted therapies stem cell therapy
targeted immunotherapy and each
individual and I'm going to predict that
the combinations of targeted therapies
and immunotherapy are going to be
extremely effective more effective than
either one of these alone the next
question is one that I alluded to
briefly which is the concept of how do
you determine whether a mutation is a
driver or a passenger that's another
full talk that I give in in
other environments one of the obvious
things that one can do is ask whether
this aberration is commonly seen and has
been characterized by others to be a
driver event in cancer and that's
probably the best way that we have today
v600e mutation in b-raf mutations within
the region of v600e are clearly drivers
other common aberrations and pi3 kinase
are clearly drivers they've been
extensively characterized there are a
number of algorithms that have been
demonstrated or developed to attempt to
predict which our drivers and passengers
and I will tell you that they are not
very effective indeed we looked at the
nine current algorithms with a thousand
different aberrations from the Cancer
Genome Atlas and not one of them was
called the same dilla Tereus by all nine
algorithms so we need better approaches
and this is a major program in at the md
anderson cancer center and even more so
in my own personal laboratory now i want
to go to a question that's a little
further down the list is what are the
bioinformatics challenges and is this an
opportunity for career development I'm
going to be very excited in saying that
even though we have great challenges
right now with funding and positions in
cancer in general cancer research in
general the one area where there are
major opportunities is around
bioinformatics and being able to link
biology informatics and patient care
this is critical it is massive we are
generating data at a rate that we have
never done before and in reality the one
of the major rate limiting challenges we
have is in handling and analyzing that
data now I mentioned the concept that we
can sequence a genome for a thousand
dollars I actually think that is
insufficient depth to be useful but I
can certainly see
once the actionable genome that which I
need to know about for a thousand
dollars the estimate today though is it
is going to cost us a hundred thousand
dollars to determine what in that genome
is important to manage that's partly why
we've developed the personalized cancer
therapy website so that people can
benefit from the major efforts and
investment we're making in identifying
drivers and determining what to do about
them but this is going to be that
challenge for the future okay so one of
the questions that came up is one that I
related to are needed to do we need to
obtain new biopsies on every patients
can you get the information that you
need from circulating DNA and can you
get that information from circulating
tumor cells or imaging at this point in
time the gold standard remains
characterization of the patient tumor I
think that is critical and we need to
use that and continue with that is what
we're doing I think that the opportunity
of moving to circulating DNA and
circulating tumor cells is great but
that we will need to determine how and
when that is effective and when it can
replace biopsies so for a while biopsies
are the standard of care okay we have
one or two more questions that we can
answer i'm going to leave it up to the
organizers as to whether we can go a few
minutes over an hour broadcast time one
of those is to ask are there new methods
used to treat cancer I think I've
already alluded to this and I want to
come back I believe that the future
Cancer Care is going to be integration
the methods that we are using today
but much better ways to integrate that
information so targeted therapies going
beyond what I talked about I did not
talk about transcriptomics metabolomics
methyl omics all other opportunities
that are arising combined with targeted
immunotherapy some cases of stem cell
therapy and putting that into an
armamentarium where we can pick the
right patients to move forward I want to
finish with one final question which is
what do I consider the minimum clonal
rates of mutations in a primary tumor to
worry about and I wish I could answer
this in a definitive manner right now we
use a cut off of the aberration
occurring in five percent of the tumor
cells as the minimum amount that we can
work with when we look at the estrogen
receptor abnormalities and ask whether a
person will benefit from ER targeted
therapy 1% of the tumor cells being
er-positive is considered to signal an
abnormality that is worthwhile treating
so right now we have put a cut-off as
five percent i think is our technology
improves it may go on even better and we
can get down to one percent but that is
going to require clinical trials and a
lot more work to answer the questions so
I think that I've now gone over all of
the key questions that we have and
responded in in either directly or
indirectly and I would like to close
this today and say thank you for your
attention and I hope this has been
useful these slides will be made
available for you to look at at your
leisure at another time thank you